This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Rob.
And I'm Sam.
So, how are you today, Sam?
Oh, don't ask, Rob. Today's been a nightmare.
This morning, I ripped my jeans and later my computer stuff working.
Then when I tried taking it to a repair shop, my car wouldn't start.
Oh, no, that's terrible.
And the really bad news is that in today's consumer culture,
when something breaks, we usually throw it away and buy a new one,
instead of trying to repair it.
In this programme, we'll learn all about repairing broken things
by asking what would happen if we stopped
junking and got better at fixing.
The world generates over two billion tons of rubbish every year.
So, we're visiting companies in Sweden,
making it easier to mend things when they break,
instead of replacing them, whether that's clothes, bikes or washing machines.
A Mike Wis question is about one of those companies, Fixie,
a repair service that collects broken bikes from your door
and brings them back fixed.
The company was started by Raffi Mahamid,
a student of industrial innovation at the University of Stockholm.
But what was the inspiration behind Raffi's idea?
Was it A, he wanted to impress his girlfriend?
B, he was sick of breathing in the city's car fumes,
or C, he was late for his lecture because of a flat tire.
Also A, he wanted to impress his girlfriend.
Okay, Sam, we'll find out about Raffi and his love life later on.
But whatever the inspiration behind it, Raffi's idea was a success.
Fixie took more than 600 orders in its first six months.
Raffi isn't the only Swedish company helping people fix things instead of buying new.
Denham Company Newdy Jeans was started with a focus on ethics and sustainability.
At $150 a pair, Newdy Jeans aren't cheap,
but they do promise free repairs for life.
From Ripney's to Torn pockets.
BBC World Service Programme People Fixing the World
asked students Felix and Fabian Morgan why they bought the Jeans despite the high price tag.
It's just been given that when your jeans break, you throw them away.
So when I heard that you can be repaired them easily without any costs,
there was a bit of a no-brainer for me.
I really liked waiting in the book.
So for me, it's worth it to buy more expensive but stuff that I really like.
Felix says that throwing out old jeans is a given, something that is just assumed to happen.
For him, buying Newdy Jeans is a no-brainer, a decision that's very easy to make.
And Fabia agrees. She doesn't mind paying more for stuff she really likes.
Here, stuff is an informal way to say personal objects and possessions.
Even though they're good at recycling, people in wealthy Sweden still buy lots of new stuff
and they have a big carbon footprint for a country of just 10 million.
But it's interesting that all the innovators behind these companies say that in their grandparents day,
it was normal to repair, fix and mend broken stuff.
Jessica Ricksert is a researcher at Lung University.
She thinks repairing is an endangered activity that we use to do more of,
both individually and as a society.
Here she is talking to BBC World Services people fixing the world program
about the need to get back in touch with older ways of doing things.
Really is a pure effect and a culture that we're trying to foster here,
changing a culture of consumption. The more people that are repairing and the more people that
are choosing to buy repair services or more repairable products, the more we will see this going
mainstream and it used to be mainstream. So that's what makes me positive too.
That it is in some ways a return to what we used to be able as a society to do more of.
Stories about Sweden's repair shops spread between friends and Jessica thinks this creates a
peer effect. The positive or negative influence friends have on the way you behave.
She hopes this will foster or encourage to grow a new culture of sustainable consumption
so that fixing broken stuff will be mainstream or be considered normal once again.
Yes that's a big part of the problem. Repairing was something we all used to do but seem to have
forgotten. Hopefully we'll all be inspired to start fixing things again or at least pay someone
else too. And speaking of inspiration, what was the answer to your quiz question Rob?
Ah yes I asked about the inspiration behind Raffi Muhammad's company Fixi.
And I think he started the bike repair service to a impresser's girlfriend. Was I right?
Ah Sam that's very romantic but the correct answer was see he was late for his lecture because
of a flat tire. Oh well I'm sure if he had a broken heart he'd be able to mend it.
Indeed. Well in this program we've been hearing about repairing broken stuff, things or personal
that people would fix something broken used to be a given assumed to be true or certain to happen.
Repairing things used to be a no-brainer the obvious choice. A peer effect is influence appears
in friends on someone's behaviour. Some Swedish companies are trying to foster or encourage
the development of a new culture of consumption. So that once again fixing things is mainstream
accepted as normal or common practice. Well that's all from us. Bye for now. Bye bye.